Shark Attack is playing there with a lot of
creativity she plays rolling ball
that's it and comes again attack passes second
account with a pool and there was a drop
of half again let's see if she comes back she
tried just say that I have one more chance
seeing attack-defense do  an opportunity
you think here suffering connected will
ask you for the money again
Filipinho looked for us I paid it's worth it weak that
they weren't court for cos survey
analyzed passes back Renan
receiving the ball Franklin Mint got up for
that one to leave it here went to get it call
Luiz  Felipe asking for approval maybe
Franklin and his uncle are seeing Franco in
Tinguá bumping his head Felipe Harley
finished Renan in the Forno Quadra
managed to get it go plant here my
uncle came deep coverage on WhatsApp
little doesn't end Vale Renan interminable
change that Franklin is coming there ok  deep down here,
my defense against a blow
will not come back clothes got
up it was a chicken He works fell